all right dad this is really the the
theme hour uh no excuse excuses
my single mom yeah started at around 45
46 years old
we don't know what happened up to that
point right but at that point you start
with zero
yep and you have a million dollars in
your 401ks and an almost paid for
300 000 house where we reach over and
pay it off
and uh net worth does not change by the
way when you do that
because you're reducing the debt by the
exact same amount you reduce the savings
and so our net worth remains the same
and uh she's got plenty of money left to
live on and not a payment in the
freaking world
and she's a millionaire nurse at 66
years old
please america remember you can do this
oh my gosh i don't know how i mean i've
got to spoon feed some of you
unbelievable what's it take to make some
of you believe
that'll do it man that's incredible wow
absolutely incredible hey kelly keep up
with her absolutely i want to
i want to talk to her later oh yeah
that's good man that's amazing
absolutely that's just because my gosh i
mean wow
because here's the thing when you're 45
yeah and let's call it a divorce i don't
know what happened maybe her husband
passed away i don't know
right but but um something happened yes
and you're by yourself yep
you got no money and you got kids
what are you gonna do yeah well
you know women can't get ahead
well you know single moms they don't
have a chance
hey and then you could believe that you
can sit in the corner suck your thumb
and hope that the government will take
care of you at retirement
or you can go be a student yes wow what
a stud
that's amazing 66 years old
21 years later she's a millionaire as
a nurse she's not a lawyer
she didn't play in the nba and she
doesn't have a rock band
she just did the practical things that
we teach
get out of debt and vest and live below
your means because our house is not even
that expensive dave like you could tell
she literally
did our stuff when she learned about it
and it works yeah bottom line and now i
got people listening to me right now
that are broke living in a million two
house
right yeah driving two freaking cars in
the driveway they're 50 000 a piece and
you fleeced them
and then you're scratching your head and
crying because america had any
opportunity no you're just stupid yeah
that's the only problem anything to do
with opportunities got through as stupid
you're just walking around wearing
stupid around your neck every day and
then wondering why you're broke
no excuses you know this is cray cray
man
i love that woman she's so inspiring
because she represents the fact that you
if you're listening to me right now
you can do this yeah now dave now since
she's at the retirement age she has a
million dollars let's say well she has
about
800 000 cash liquid in her 401k does she
pull from a 401k or does she just live
off the interest
oh definitely living off the interest
yeah i mean what's the ballpark of
interest you think
i mean if she's got 800 000 and it made
10 percent that'd be 80 grand
right that's abuse which is probably
more than she was making
exactly all about to say with no bills
80 grand a year that's a beautiful
salary for someone else
he's living in a 300 000 house 66 years
old
shut up wow that's just dr i mean this
jams me up right here wow
i'm telling you guys i i um i
i i understand pain
yeah from having done stupid things i
have been in a pile
of stupid myself that i made for myself
so i know exactly what it looks like i
know exactly how it feels
but what i will not accept from any of
you
is that you can't do it so good
henry ford said if you think you can or
you think you can't you're right
yep and uh is it hard well of course
it's hard
yeah if it wasn't hard every little
duper would do it
every little wuss would do it no you got
to be a stud you got to be a student to
do it right
got to but dave listen about it i want
it it's hard
and i want it to be hard because later
on it's going to be
easier so now her retirement is easier
because she was willing to put into work
and work like no one else does if it's
easy up front it's going to be hard in
the ending
it's which end do you want to pay it on
there you go dave
and how big a price you want to pay by
the way if you pay the price up front
it's a smaller price
absolutely here's the idea you retire at
65. you live
25 years on social insecurity
eleven to thirteen hundred dollars a
month eating alpo
or you can freaking do this stuff one of
the two
which price do you want to pay i'm you
know
you may not go on vacation you don't
want me dave ramsey doesn't want me to
have any fun
oh shut up i want you to have the
biggest fun
ever yes and you can have the biggest
fun ever when you have some
money and you're not broken whiny let's
go dave
oh my gosh this is awesome what a neat
lady should fire me up can you tell
yes i think the whole hour fired us up